He was the father of fascism,
the iron fisted dictator who ruled
Italy for more than two decades.
During that time,
he punched his country into disaster
forming an alliance with adult Hitler and
is bringing the wrath of the wells and
his own people upon him. In the end,
his own citizens express their own
roofless verdict on the man who called
himself. He'll do chain and
this week's biographics.
We track the life and the
death of Benito Mussolini.
Benito, I'll mill, could I and dre. And
Mussolini was born on the 29th of July,
1883 and a small village near
the northern Italian town of pet.
Happy Yo in the province of folly.
His father and rather Sandra was a
blacksmith and an atheist who was heavily
involved in socialist politics while his
mother Rosa was a devout Roman Catholic
school teacher with his
parents divergent beliefs.
The young Mr Linny was raised to put his
faith in both Karl Marx and the pope.
His mother took him to mass several times
a week while his father dragged him to
the pub to learn from his
socialist friends from the start.
Benito proved to be an aggressive and
rebellious child and later life he
recalled I was not a good boy.
I was,
I believe on really by the time he was
eight Mussolini was spending long hours
helping us father in the furnace.
Here he would listen to Alessandra is
socialist ideas and these words are mold
his future philosophy,
but the wise heart was with his mother.
He feared displeasing, Huh? Yes. This
did not curb his way with tendencies.
By the time he was nine Raisa had become
so exasperated with Benito that she
sends him to a school run
by Roman Catholic monks in
order to instill some much
needed discipline.
The defines Benito Chafed at the strict
discipline and his behavior became even
worse.
He got into a number of fights and was
eventually expelled when he took on one
of the monks,
Rosa,
no center wayward son to a less
strict school closer to home.
This though it did nothing to improve
his behavior and his before long he was
expelled.
This time for threatening
and other students with a
knife has exasperated mother
nine inch to find a third school where
he managed to see artists schooling or
the age of 17 Benito completed his
10 years of compulsory schooling.
His main accomplishments over that
time web, not really academic.
Rather he learned how to play the
trombone and speak in public. However,
despite his poor academic record in
1901 he qualified as a school teacher,
but he seemed discovered that
teaching did not suit him.
He was far more interested in the two
passions that he had inherited from his
father, socialism and womanizing. The
18 year olds. Benito was a strong,
handsome man with a forceful
personality and a certain charisma.
He easily drew the attention of young
women, often the wives of other men.
There's often resulted in him having
fistfights with people's husbands,
often less than a year muscly,
and he had lost his teaching job after
getting into a violence arguments with no
money and it's very visceral prospects.
He moved to Switzerland.
He worked in eight succession of manual
jobs to support himself within a short
time he had attached himself
to a group of Marxists.
He also joined a trade union.
Nan's began attending rival political
rallies where he would hack all the
sneaker and start fights
with those in the crowd.
As a result of these political agitations,
Benito was arrested and deported
back to Italy several times,
but each time he returned to Switzerland's
more determined than ever to keep
Stuttering v political pot.
[inaudible] struggle to make
ends meet and Switzerland.
On one occasion he accosted two elderly
women on the street and stole food for
them. In his 1928 auto biography. He
related that if the women had struggles,
he would have strangled them.
In 1904 he returned to it to the end,
he joins the Italian army he served
out has compulsory 18 months,
10 months into his military service.
Miscellaneous beloved mother Rosa.
She died a distraught of Benito laser
called this the greatest sorrow of his
life.
He was discharged from the
army in September of 1906
he had clearly not learned
discipline while in this country
service as his life now revolved around
drinking,
womanizing and fighting,
he managed to gain employment as a teacher
again with a succession of temporary
contracts. During this period
prior to the first world war,
listening to his moral character
deteriorated as socialists socialist ardor
increased.
He wrote four and edited several
Socialists newspapers running against the
government, the democratic
system, the middle classes,
and the church and one pamphlets
incisal to God. It does not exist.
He rose to the priests were black
microbes who are as faithful to mankind as
tuberculosis germs when it's
entered in a war against Libya.
In 1911 Mysoline he led the internal
criticism against the government's actions
through his newspaper writings.
He's outspoken.
Opposition led to his arrest and
it's a five month imprisonment. Yes,
his fist shaking public
opposition to the government.
I'd also gone to the attention of the
country's top socialist leaders who looked
on admiringly.
The young Benito Mussolini was viewed
by them as a rising star of the left in
December of 1912 shortly
after his release from prison,
but he's was appointed editor of the
country's national socialist newspaper
goals,
Avanti.
It was a natural fit and within six
months is firebrand style of journalism.
I had increased the papers readership
five fold now have a national forum with
which to air is for use.
When war broke house in 1914 Mr Leni
held firm non-interventionist views.
He saw war as anti-socialist does it
pitted the working classes of one nation
against those of another.
Within months he had changed his view.
He now saw war is an
opportunity for revolution.
He now used his voice through the pages
of Avante to call on the young men of
Italy to join the army. What's the name
is about face on the war situation,
put him at odds with more moderate
socialists leaders and resulted in his
expulsion from the party and it's the
loss of, is that a ship of the paper?
Defiantly he started his own newspaper,
ill popular Italia or
the people of vessels.
This paper ran continuously from November,
1914 it's almost Selenis
removal from power.
29 years later in his first editorial,
he proclaimed the famous line blood
alone moves the wheels of history.
Around this same time,
Mr Leni founded his first political party,
the FASC over revolutionary action.
This was soon simply known as the
fascist party, the main allied powers,
Britain and France supported Mussolini,
seeing him as a key to getting Italy
more involved in the war effort.
They provided much needed
financial support to the new party.
The British secret service, even paid
muscly need a wage of 100 pounds per week.
In July of 1915 is at least signs the
treaty of London committing itself to
fighting alongside the allies
against Germany. But it isn't.
These war soon became a fiasco.
It was plagued by poorly trained and
experienced officers and unwilling
belligerent conscripts.
They became bogged down and a battle
of attrition against Austria, Hungary.
By the time it was all over,
more than 650,000 Italians would add
half a million we're missing and nearly a
million.
Where we ended was Eleni himself.
[inaudible] joined the army in September
of 1915 he attained the rank of
corporal winning a claim for his
bravery and devotion to his men.
On February the 20 seconds 1917 he
was in a trench when one of his fellow
soldiers grenades exploded.
He was badly wounded requiring numerous
operations over the course of the next
month, and then he was sent
home to recuperate, was the,
his message now morphed from socialism
and the plate of the working man to
patriotism as the cause
of ultra nationalism.
Okay.
During the postwar talks in Paris,
Italy,
it was treated dismissively
by the major powers,
the territories that she had been promised
to during the 1915 treaty of London
when not handed over the
Italian prime minister,
Vittoria Orlando walked out of
the conference in total disgust.
Orlando bore the brunt of the public
discontent and we're soon removed from
office and the following elections,
miscellaneous fascist party
failed to win a single seat.
His political rivals made fun of this
staging and mock funeral for the party
chief among his adversaries,
where the Socialists Seward won a third
of the seats in parliament and ticking.
Most Illini was now firmly opposed
to over the next three years.
The political situation and instantly
was extremely unstable with four prime
ministers and coalition governments.
None of these was able to yield
any real power. The country.
It was in a state of near anarchy with
the rampant inflation and unemployment is
driving people to total despair.
Mussolini's Fascist, stressed,
and they're intimidating black
shirts rooms through the streets,
seeking out and beating up socialists,
communists or anyone who they didn't
like the look of the police who have
sympathy for the fascists usually stood
by and let muscle in his mat and get
away with it.
On May the 15th of 1921 national elections
were held this time the fascists join
day coalition of rightwing parties,
the national block,
and as the one that 35 seats out of the
total of 535 in the house of parliament.
Mussolini himself gained a seat
and the Chamber of Deputies,
he was now an official member of the
Italian government realizing that he now
needed to broaden his base.
Most of the knee did an about face on
a couple of is underpinning principles.
He became both pro Monica pro church,
but his hatred of socialism.
That certainly remains.
Mussolini renames the potty now calling
it the national fascist party is
reputation began to grow and he became
known as a man with the ability to rule
with a firm hands and restore order amidst
the chaos that Italy had fallen into,
public opinion was actually
beginning to turn in his favor.
That popularity was bolstered when
Mussolini's black shirts broke up his
socialist back strike in October of
1922 at a rally. Shortly thereafter,
Mosley need declared in the speech that
either the government would hand over
power to him or he would
seize it for himself,
and this was no idle bluster with no
sign of capitulation by the government.
Mussolini decided to stage a coup
by marching on Rome. His forces,
though they were no match for the Italian
army, but still the prime minister,
Luigi factor offered Mussolini a position
in his government in order to avoid
conflict. The offer was roundly rejected
and the fascists marched on the capital.
The panics.
Prime Minister urged the king to
allow him to use the army to quash the
rebellion.
The king agreed.
He quickly changed his mind fairing
that a civil war with breakouts,
there's enraged the prime minister who
ultimately resigned from his office.
The 28,000 fascists marching on the
Capitol stops 20 miles north of the city.
That half of them left
to often written time.
The rest carries on with Mussolini
himself joining them at various points to
have his photo taken at the front of the
line. But with the rain pouring down,
he was content to leave the
heavy marching to others.
And took an express train and Rome,
the king who secretly admired Mussolini
now tried to play Katen by offering him
a governmental role.
Mussolini,
though he would consider nothing
but the prime ministership.
Eventually the king
offered him the position.
By Age 39 muscle Ini had become prime
minister, not through violence revolution,
but through threat bluster and unequivocal
demands in the wake of his victory.
Ecstatic fascists rooms the streets in
search of downhearted socialists that
they could terrorize.
Mm.
Mussolini was now both Prime
Minister and foreign minister,
but his government was very much a
majority in the house of parliament.
This forced him to work within
the confines of democracy,
which left and at the mercy you if the
majority coalition this though it was not
a situation that the power hungry
autocratic would tolerate for very long.
Within eight weeks of assuming office
muscle lenient forms of the fascist grand
council,
the grand council acted as a conduit
between the fascists and the Chamber of
deputies filled with his hand,
picked appointees. It was in effect,
a mouthpiece for most Illini,
which effectively lessens the
power of parliament to act.
In 1923 the grand council passed a law
that rigged the electoral system to
ensure that the fascists gains a
sizable majority in the next election.
When the election was
held the following April,
the fascists won 374 of the 535 seats.
This new law had certainly helps
them gain the 70% majority,
but sue did the vigilance presence of
miscellaneous black chefs who co asked the
public to vote for the fascists. In
addition, opposition party meetings,
we're broken up and the
candidates were beaten.
In the wake of this
overwhelming electoral victory.
Socialists leader Jack Mo matter Yachty
openly it denounced the fascists and
their leader. 11 days later,
Matty Yachty was assassinated.
This led to nationwide protests against
most lenient is party of thugs with many
people are calling on the king to
depose the Prime Minister Fears Boston.
What's Illini plaid innocence and acted
shocked and revolted by the murder.
He did his best to to distance
himself from the crime.
Still politicians from
all parties responded by
withdrawing from parliaments in
an effort to force miscellaneous
ejection from office,
but the king refuse to get rid of most
of the knee and a vote of confidence.
On January the third 1925 a few of the
prime minister's opponents showed up
after the opportunists team now took
the opportunity to cement his absolute
authority.
He declared that only the fascists could
provide stability in the country and it
would be achieved through dictatorship.
That's the most Selenis propaganda
machine infiltrated every area of Italy.
A cult of personality develops around him.
People consider them to be a genius man
of action, but one with a common touch.
When things went well, it was all
thanks to all [inaudible] the leader.
However it when things went wrong,
it was never his fault.
He was a mesmerizing speaker.
He used facial expressions and gestures.
Do you capture and then
throw all his audience.
He stood at only at five foot six inches
and likes to dress and striped trousers
and shirts with butterfly colors.
He was not a well man,
physically suffering from
ulcers and stomach upsets.
His health problems forced him
to give up smoking and drinking.
I'm beginning to lose his hair.
In his late twenties he
took just shaving his hat.
He was also short sighted
to vent wear glasses.
What's the Leni spend the next two
years dismantling democracy and so they
understand wishing his own
totalitarian regime. During that time,
he instilled three key messages into
the public consciousness, believe,
obey and fight.
This message gained widespread approval.
Even many former socialists now turn
to fascism the farm hands of the state.
We're seen as the only
solution to the country's woes.
All forms of criticism of the state
where bands and opposition parties were
disbanded was Leni himself,
was answerable only to the king.
Spies were everywhere and he
gets a report to the authorities.
Anyone who spoke or acted against the
state during the 1920 is the fascists have
made modest improvements in
the Italian economy. However,
all of this was over turns with the
global depression that followed the Wall
Street crash in October
of 1929 once again,
the country went into a
state of economic chaos.
What's the lenient responded by embarking
on foreign invasions during the 1930s
he's sent armies into Libya, Ethiopia
and Spain. Italy's invasion of Ethiopia.
Yeah.
Began in 1935 and resulted
in a devastating occupation
that would continue until
1941 when the British army forced
the Italians out. During that time,
it has been estimated that 8% of
Ethiopia's population was put to death.
Mussolini. You ordered that the
male populations of entire towns,
the wipes out if EOP is leader Haile
Selassie was forced to flee to England's
where he petitions the United Nations.
This infuriated by selenium and sent him
into the arms of a neighboring dictator
by the name of adult Ed Blah.
On May the 20 seconds, 1939 Hitler
and Mussolini signed a Pact of steel.
This man's that they promised to come to
each other's aid in the event of walk.
Less than four months later up Germany
invaded Poland igniting world war to
whistler.
Leni approved erratic in its response to
the prospect of fighting a European war
alongside the Nazis. On the very day
that Germany invaded, Poland is Mysoline.
He announced to his cabinets because
he had decided not to fulfill his
obligation from the pact of steel on
the basis that Germany has signed a
nonaggression pact with the Soviet Union
and act that violated the providers of
the pact.
The truth was that muscle meaning you
had absolutely no confidence and it's
country's readiness for war,
despite his announcement to his cabinet,
most of them, and you continue to put
up a pretense of support for headlamp.
However, in private, he spoke of joining
the British and French coalition.
Finally on June the 10th,
1940 with the Nazi's looking,
I should have an easy victory over the
French Mussolini declared war on Britain
and France,
Italian troops where I quickly sent to
France in order that Mr he could have
some share in the spoils of victory.
At the same time,
he mobilized forces into Africa
to attack British Holdings.
That large scale forces were sent into
Egypt while other divisions focused on
Greece.
At the same time,
Mr meaning it was overseeing the air force
as they joins with the Nazi Luftwaffe.
Uh,
in the battle of Britain in every theater,
the ill prepared Italian forces were
driven back or stalemated this enraged at
la who was forced to send German
troops in to save the Italians.
By the beginning of 1942, it was a
Paris, Italy was fighting a losing war.
They were badly beaten in
Egypt at the battle of Al Amin,
and the allied invasion of French north
Africa pushed them further back on their
heels. The allied invasion of
Sicily was the final Straw is,
are these complete to feet?
It was only a matter of time.
The country was in a state of
emergency if there was no fuel.
So all the factories
were not working for you.
It was incredibly scas with
widespread starvation resulting.
The people were desperate and
they were furious in this climate.
A massive march on Rome took place
in March, again, still to Che,
bowing to the will of the people.
King Victor Emmanuel ordered Mussolini
to his palace where he informed him that
he was removing him from
office gods then came in,
arrested most Illini and
took him into custody venue.
Italian Prime Minister Pietro by Dalia
was intense on breaking the alliance with
Germany and signing an armistice
with the allies. However,
in order to stall for time, he kept up
the ruse of an alliance with Hitler.
Unsurprisingly,
when Hitler learns that the new ruler
had signed an armistice on September the
third in 1943 he was furious.
He ordered a full scale
invasion of his former ally.
Nazi forces used to blitzkrieg tactics
do you storm and capture room forcing the
king and it's prime
minister to flee the city.
Some elements of the Italian
army attempted to resist,
but many of them simply threw down
their arms and surrendered. Meanwhile,
muscly and he was being held at a
resort towns prison in the Alps.
He knew the situation was chaotic.
That was surprised to see German and
standing right outside of a cell window.
Video admins quickly overpowered the
gods and made their way into most of the
new cell. Why? One of
them said, elder chain,
the furor and to me to
set you free most of the,
and he was taken to hit list
East Prussia headquarters.
Hitler genuinely admired my and considered
him a great influence on his own
career,
but he was disappointed to see the man
before him all of Mysoline his will to
continue the fascist struggle, a
deserted him. The fear was dumbfounded.
When was the lady asked if he could be
permitted to retire from public life?
Hello,
we'd have none of us.
If you installed Mussolini as the
puppet ruler of northern Italy,
which was now in the hands of
the Nazis for the next 18 months,
my Illini played this role and impotent
leader who ruled over a people who hated
him all the while he
was surrounded by arms,
Nazis and the approaching allies with
the writing well and truly on the wall.
Most selenium trying to
escape to Switzerland's on
April the 27th of 1945 just
short of the border,
he was intercepted by communists suit,
took him and his companions into custody.
The following day.
They decided to execute him along with
his long time mistress Clara Petacci.
After riddling the bodies with bullets,
the Communists drove them into Milan and
dumped them in the middle of the town
square for hours.
The citizens of Milan to accounts,
they're amnesty on the man who had led
them to disaster his body. It was spat on,
stoned,
beaten,
and finally strung up by the feet that
are the body of the ones who revered
leader was subjected to
the abuse of the Kraut.
His corpse was eventually
thrown into an unmarked grave.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel
for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday. Also, I've gotten
another channel. It's called today.
I found out it's sort of like biographics,
but way more broad on that channel.
We get deep into all sorts of details
on all sorts of interesting stuff.
Check it out through the
link on the screen now,
but if you're looking for
something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the
archives over there on the rights or
indeed to today?
I found out video.
Anyways,
thank you for watching.